[Musique]
alors qu'il paraît pas la grille oui
j'ai la grippe et je viens quand même
bien vivre comme ça pas de la grippe tue
à distance mais ce regard des caméras ça
va moyen mais je suis quand même là pour
le leur nous voilà au lancement
international du honor view 20 alors
j'ai vu il ya quelques jours déjà été
pris en main j'ai commencé un peu à
découvrir
lorsque j'étais à l'hôtel mgm à las
vegas aux crs étaient cool donc il ya
tout le monde qui attendent la
présentation aura lieu d'ici quelques
temps à mon avis
ça va être un événement énorme les salle
pleyel à paris
ça aurait dit cela il ya énormément de
monde
je pense que les votes avec fallout di
fiemme it entretien quand même bah oui
on a bon jour qui sait ce qu'il en
existe il manque un petit noeud papillon
ou l'être alors à ce moment là vers
l'alaska peut-être un ou deux boutons et
il serait bien faire après les
accueillir et le malt voix et paul
thomas prêtres et predica voir la glace
ne changeant rien dit parce que vous en
pensez en commentaire pour moi de
changer
[Musique]
maintenant il est l'heure de partir de
la salle pleyel
j'ai le
avec moi ce que je propose c'est que là
je suis hyper hyper à la bourget un
eurostar
direction londres ce qu'on se fait ses
classes au final on
propres un petit peu de temps pour
l'ouvrir boxing rapide et puis on enfin
dans quelques jours
beaucoup
regardez moi cette chambre bien arrivé à
londres
je suis franchement excentré pas près du
centre mais le spot est juste ouf c'est
le bémol free du hilton c'est juste
incroyable
regardez la chambre ça envoie du bois
grave c'est juste énorme et envoyez pas
je vous montrerai plus tard dans une
autre vidéo demain au fond là bas là
vous avez la tamise au fond c'est la
classe à dallas ce que la classe à
londres c'est franchement superbe au la
fiole avec le petit bard j'adore ce
court la grande salle de bain qui juste
énormissime grande baignoire là je pense
que ça va envoyer du bois
là ce que je vous propose c'est il est
quelque chose comme
23 heures heure de londres il est minuit
heure française on se fait un petit
homme boxing on regarde rapidement
comment il s'est fait comment est la
boîte du honor view 20 ce qui lie à
l'intérieur et puis on sera un test
complet d'ici quelques jours on se fera
un test global du smartphone et on sera
aussi un test photo vidéo parce qu'il
faut voir vraiment content de cette
caméra de 48 mégapixels là on arrivait à
à l'ombre pour parler de microsoft alors
je vous en parle dans quelques jours
parce que pour l'instant je vous dit pas
tout j'ai un peu d'argent pendant je
suis fier d'arriver sur danger est là
j'ai toutes les infos sur le bet 2019
c'est un événement est lié aux
technologies et à l'éducation c'est un
truc de ouf on en parle peut-être pas
demain peut-être après demain le temps
de tout voir ailleurs qu'un plein de
trucs hyper cool ça c'est un truc qui
est complètement complètement dingue est
vraiment inédit
alors avant même de parler du bet dans
quelques jours tout de suite ressenti
sur le honor view va alors qu'est ce que
le videur de la boîte smartphones ça
c'est quoi ça voilà vache c'est un
système pour faire des photos de lui
honor 3 des visuels charbon ça s'est
ouvert il a tous les côtés on verra ça
plus en détail quand on fait la partie
photo
par contre je vous dis tout de suite la
partie photo d'elle va être complètement
dry je vais vous emmener dans les îles
pour le faire on parle pas plus pour
l'instant voilà la boîte du au nord du
vin je sais les conditions ne sont pas
optimales pour servane boxxy mais je
suis dans un hôtel à londres c'est la
nuit je fais comme je peux c'est un ace
la toute petite encoche là ils ont
franchement bien intégré ça c'est hyper
cool hop le fantôme blue hyper casse
alors il ya des gens qui vont aimer il
ya des gens qui vont détester ce doux
ces types et c'est vraiment très
particulier mais par contre ça quand
même de la classe après vraiment c'est
une question de goût on aime on n'aime
pas mais je reçois pas mal moins alors
qu'est ce qu'on a dans la boîte à
l'intérieur laisse ses mots jeter un
coup d'oeil
de quoi ouvrir son tiroir de cartes sim
bien
mon â on a une petite coque de
protection plastique s'est pas
complètement dingos c'est pas les coques
les plus belles après elle est
transparente
elle permet quand même de protéger on
garde quand même l'effet 3d
bon c'est pas ce qu'il ya de plus beau
mais franchement ça marche ensuite c'est
très très très sommaire c'est vraiment
rare un homme boxing très très court on
à la prise usb type c usb ça c'est cool
et on a le bloc de charges super charge
donc ça aussi c'est franchement cool
petit allumage en bonne et due forme au
nord
je suis très content parce que ce
smartphone j'ai déjà pu le voir lorsque
j'étais à vegas il ya pas longtemps et
la deuxième impression c'est pas la
produire l'impression savez deuxième
premières impressions franchement c'est
cool je vous le fais perd rapidement me
regarder si vous jeter un petit coup
d'oeil là vous verrez qu'il ya déjà une
petite découpe au niveau de l'encoche
c'est-à-dire qui a déjà un écran de
protection dessus donc ça c'est
franchement pas mal
c'est un smartphone qu'on va se tester
en long en large et en travers très très
très rapidement pour l'instant 20
vraiment rester là tu sais franchement
hyper clair à ce que je vois ça c'est
cool caméra frontale
on me voit reconnaissance des visages ça
c'est cool ce qui est bien avec ce
smartphone c'est que le format etc où
l'on trouve tout de suite le capteur
d'empreintes digitales
la prise en main franchement est juste
excellente donc c'est en tout cas ça
reste un excellent smartphone de début
2019 et on va voir si au nord
franchement donne un petit peu la
tendance de cette année avec ce système
d'encoches bon c'est tout pour ce soir
en ce qui concerne le honor view vin qui
est juste là on en reparle dans quelques
jours parce que comme je voulais dit je
vais le tester en long en large et en
travers on va se faire un test
complètement ouf
au niveau de la photo de la vidéo on va
se mettre dans un spot qui juste
incroyable on va aller à la plage au
soleil les pieds dans l'eau on croyez
moi ça va être cool
et puis vous invite à visionner la vidéo
que j'ai fait aux 6es avec gas de
découvert du smartphone comme ça je vous
en parle un peu plus vrai tout les specs
vous saurez exactement ce qu'on peut
faire avec mais franchement ils allaient
à hyper prometteur et puis surtout il
permet d'emmener au nord dans un nouveau
type d'écran dans un nouveau design dans
un nouvel écran et rien que pour ça
c'est franchement hyper coûte rien je
vous invite à me dire ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire mans vous trouvez
ce au nord du vin est ce que vous pensez
que au nord à faire
l'ong boulot dessus est ce que vous
aimez ce système de petites encoches
voilà vous marquez tout ça on reste
connectés bien évidemment et puis là on
retourne faire un petit tour car salut c
moi on est un petit tôt et si regardez
moi ça c'est juste magnifique j'adore
cette chance
c'est la grande classe ah la la tamise
au loin on la devine légèrement avec le
honor view 20 juste devant c'est
magnifique
il est temps pour moi de les manger un
beau ensuite d'aller faire le montage de
patin mais trop tard parce que demain
énorme journée ça va envoyer du bois
n'oubliez pas de marquer en bas ce que
vous pensez de ce ono review 20 on reste
ensemble et puis j'avais rendez vous
très très très très très vite
et n'oubliez pas le test arrive